Hey everybody, welcome to the podcast.
The focus of today's episode is on the innovation
of alternative proteins.
How plant-based and cultivated meat
hold this amazing potential to mitigate
the deleterious environmental impact of food systems,
decrease the risk of zoonotic disease,
ameliorate animal suffering,
and ultimately feed more people with fewer resources.
My guest for this discussion back for his third appearance
on the podcast is Bruce Friedrich.
Bruce is the founder and president
of the Good Food Institute,
an international non-profit focused on facilitating
the reimagination of meat production.
He's also a TED Fellow with two fantastic TED talk
that you should all check out.
He's a Y Combinator alum and a popular speaker
on food innovation at places like Harvard, Yale, Princeton,
Stanford, and MIT.
He's been profiled in the New York Times
and many other prominent outlets and penned op-eds
for the Wall Street Journal, USA Today, Los Angeles Times,
Wired, and many other publications.
Our conversation reviews the latest developments
in both plant-based and cultured meat,
how technological breakthroughs and things like
fermentation, 3D printing and fungi
or Micro protein harvesting are changing the game.
We also discuss the political and regulatory landscape
that frames the alternative protein landscape
and the policy changes we need to realize
to fuel a better food landscape for all.
But mostly this is an optimistic forecast of food system
innovation, how technology, urgency, and popular demand
are rapidly converging to create healthy, sustainable,
and compassionate solutions to help solve
our current food health and environmental crises.
Bruce is super smart.
This episode is I think, our smartest yet.
So, please take a moment to hit that subscribe button
if you haven't already and enjoy the conversation.
(upbeat music)
All right, Bruce, good to see you.
Thank you for coming out.
This'll be our third turn on the podcast wheel.
Always good to see you my friend.
I'm delighted to be here, Rich,
thank you so much for having me.
So you are on the cover of eating well magazine this month
as one of their food heroes, congrats.
Thank you very much.
Yeah, cool.
It's really a nice honor for GFI and what we're up to.
They picked 10, I'm one of 10-
Very good.
And the other nine
are all doing just spectacularly important work.
So it's nice to see plant-based and cultivated meat
honored in that way.
It's been amazing to see the growth trajectory of GFI.
'Cause I think the first time that we did the podcast
in a cramped hotel room in New York city,
you had just launched it or it was pretty new at that time,
I think, right?
Yeah.
We started hiring staff other than the two of us
who started it.
I guess I started it and then I hired one staff member
to launch a venture capital fund and then half a dozen
more staff members in June of 2016.
So, basically five years ago.
So, I think when we first met,
GFI was maybe a dozen team members.
Right.
And how many people do you have now?
I mean, you got offices all over the place.
Yeah, yeah.
We have north of 100, all told.
So, there's a GFI, the United States, which is about 60, 65,
and then we also have GFI affiliates in India, Israel,
Brazil, Asia Pacific, out of Singapore and Europe.
We have offices, well, an office in Brussels
and then we also have team members in London.
So, across our international affiliates, about 45 people,
and then in the U.S. about 65.
That's amazing.
In about a five-year period.
Yeah, yeah, it's been good.
Well, because it's been a minute
since the last time you were on, I can't remember.
I mean, it was at least a couple of years ago, I think.
Yeah, it's been a while.
Since you've last been here and the audience has grown or,
you know, time has elapsed.
So, I think it would be good and instructive,
if you could just briefly talk a little bit about,
the background that led you to GFI
and the mission of Good Food Institute.
Yeah.
The mission of the Good Food Institute is to figure out
how we feed close to 10 billion people by 2050
without pouring gasoline onto the planet on fire.
Ideally pour some cold water on it, put the fire out
is basically the mission.
And GFI was based on an observation that,
economies that grow, eat more meat essentially.
And the United Nations has predicted
that we will need to produce twice as much meat
by 2050 globally as we're producing right now,
most of that is going to be in developing economies,
but even in the United States,
2019 was the highest per capita meat consumption
in recorded history.
So, we were looking at ways that we can make the meat
that people apparently just really wanna consume
and do it from plants.
So, it's not veggie burgers for vegetarians
and flexitarians, it's literally,
let's biomimic the precise meat experience,
but let's do it with plants.
And instead of the inefficiency of growing massive amounts
of crops to feed them to animals so that we can eat animals,
let's feed the cells directly, let's cultivate meat
in cultivators instead of using, you know,
modern industrial farms and slaughterhouses.
And in both cases, those processes require a fraction
of the land 'cause a fraction of the adverse climate impact
and are just far more efficient.
So, much better way to feed 10 billion people and also,
huge benefits for biodiversity and climate.
Right.
A couple thoughts on that.
First of all, it's interesting that United States
just tracked its biggest meat consumption year ever
given the relative explosion of interest
in plant based diets and veganism at large,
like that movement has really grown
considerably over the last decade and yet here we are,
is that attributable to population growth?
Is attributable to an escalation and median income?
Like how do you track that?
It definitely tracks with income,
but it's per capita numbers.
So, it's not a population issue.
2019 was the highest per capita meat consumption
in recorded history in the United States,
and I think it's just food is systems one thinking.
So, the Nobel Laureate in Economics,
Daniel Kahneman in his book, "Thinking, Fast and Slow"
he talks about systems one thinking
and systems two thinking.
And even though people want to make decisions
that align with their environmental interests
and concern about biodiversity and concerned about animals,
I mean, it's the same reason people just keep getting
heavier and heavier.
We know how not to be overweight and obese and yet,
you look at the maps with color coding
and we need new colors because people just keep getting
more overweight and obese.
This is kind of the same thing.
Physiology is low on Maslow's hierarchy of needs,
food is physiology, and one thing that education
is phenomenal for is getting you involved and me involved,
it's getting people to dedicate their lives to this,
Uma Valeti started Upside Foods formerly Memphis Meats
out of concern for this and is dedicating his vocation
to it.
But as a way to get lots and lots of people to eat less
meat, which is physiology at systems one thinking
where vocation is systems two thinking,
it just doesn't seem to be working in terms of, you know,
turning the world vegetarian or vegan.
And even if we could do it in the United States, you know,
the U.S. is a place where people are best educated
about the environmental harm and the health harm
and the animal harm of eating meat
and yet even the U.S. has the highest per capita
meat consumption ever,
but most of the growth in meat production
over the next 35 years
is going to be in developing economies.
And one of the great things about making meat from plants
and cultivating meat directly from sales
is that it scales up.
So, GFI is not in Israel and Singapore
because we care what people are eating in Israel
and Singapore, we're in those countries
because they are extremely technologically
innovate advanced and because they're small,
they have food security issues,
which is motivating their governments to go all in
on making meat from plants and cultivating meat from cells.
So those are places where the technology there
can scale globally in ways that are very exciting.
Right. And you create this domino effect
by focusing on these smaller countries.
I had this guy Sergey Young here yesterday,
who's a Russian venture capitalist
focused on anti-aging technology,
and he has a similar approach focusing on smaller countries
that are more receptive in terms of, you know,
government regulation to onboard some of these ideas.
Because once you get it up on its feet in a place like that,
and the rest of the world can notice what's happening,
that sets in motion, a chain of events.
But trying to kind of push the bureaucracy
of the United States is a much taller task.
Yeah, it is unfortunately a taller task.
And then, you know, someplace like Singapore or Israel
or Japan or South Korea,
super technologically advanced governments
that support technology and support innovation.
And yeah, also a more hospitable regulatory regimes
and a lot of instances.
Right. Well, we're gonna talk about Singapore and Israel.
I mean, Singapore, just is now serving cultivated meat
in a particular restaurant there,
Israel is doing some amazing stuff with 3D printed meat,
which is insane, but I wanna start with,
this arc that you've been on.
And this ethos that I think is really powerful and important
and worthy of spending a few moments on
which is this idea that, it's easier to remake meat
than to remake morality, right?
'Cause you come from an activist background
and part of what I do here on the podcast
is try to incite individuals to make personal changes.
Which is effective to a point,
but at some stage you've recognized
the limitations of that and realize that,
if you really wanna level up and create systemic change
across these massive systems,
you have to approach it from a different perspective.
Yeah. I mean, if food is systems one thinking
and it doesn't boil down exclusively to, is it delicious
and is it affordable, but those are the two big factors.
And if we can, I mean, meat is made up of lipids, aminos,
minerals and water.
That is all meat is.
Plants also have all of those macronutrients.
If we can hire meat scientists and tissue engineers
and plant biologists, and we can figure out
how to give consumers literally, the exact same experience
from plants that they get and love from animal meat,
and it's less expensive because it's so much more efficient,
an awful lot of people will switch.
And then standard tissue engineering techniques
takes six, seven weeks to grow a chicken
from coming out of the shell to slaughter weight,
if you cultivate the cells in a cultivator,
you can get that same growth in six days,
far more efficient way to do it.
And consumers just continue to go about their lives.
It analogizes to renewable energy.
The goal of renewable energy is to simply make this
how we power our lives by making it more convenient.
Same thing with plant-based and cultivated meat.
Let's make products that taste the same or better,
and that costs the same or less.
And that science can happen anywhere,
just like renewable energy and it can scale up globally
and in the same way that, I don't have my phone here,
but my phone doesn't have a cord and it's still a phone
and it's also a camera, but it doesn't have analog film.
We can divorce meat from the need for live animals
if it, you know, if somebody eats it and they say,
this tastes exactly to me like a burger or a nugget
or whatever else that came from a slaughtered animal
but it didn't, you know, it's still meat
just like my phone's still a phone
and my camera's still a camera.
Yeah sure.
And it's important to remember that although these ideas
are perhaps new to a lot of people
and there's a period of time where we need to kind of,
wrestle with the notion of, you know,
eating a piece of animal flesh that was cultivated
from a biopsy essentially, originally
and grown in what can be likened to a brewery.
At the same time, to extend your iPhone analogy,
I mean, what was it?
20 years ago before, you know, when the iPhone didn't exist
and we lived our lives incredibly differently
compared to how we live now
and we really don't think that much about it.
Yeah, no, I mean, it was also 20 years ago
that the camera phone was invented and we went from,
no photos being taken on your phone to probably 99.9%
of photos being taken that way.
Or you think about something like in vitro fertilization,
you know, that was a huge controversy.
It was like a complete storm and now it's just completely,
completely normal.
So, I mean, I do think there's something about,
meat production now that does concern pretty much everybody
who learns about it.
I think people eat meat despite how it's produced,
not because of how it's produced.
So if you can give people meat that doesn't have
the external costs, that doesn't involve factory farms
and slaughterhouses, I don't think it's gonna be that hard
of a sell to get people thinking about meat
in whole new ways.
Yeah. Well, to further extend the camera phone analogy,
the camera phone or consumer camcorders
have played a large part in raising that awareness
regarding the ills of factory farming,
despite ad gag laws and all the measures that are in place
to prevent us from really understanding what's going on,
there is a much larger sense of reality
with respect to how our food is made.
And I think that is driving some level of consumer change,
but you can't really cross the Rubicon
with that until you make it taste just as good,
costs the same or cheaper and all the things
that you mentioned.
So, maybe we should set the stage a little bit by,
talking about the current state of global food
and animal agriculture production.
What goes into that and what the kind of deleterious
implications of that are?
Yeah, I mean GFI,
so our organizational battle cry globally is that,
governments should be funding, open access,
research and development into plant-based
and cultivated meat.
And they should be incentivizing private sector activity,
both research and development,
as well as infrastructure and manufacturing build-out.
So the things that governments care about is where we tend
to focus.
So we focus on antibiotic resistance,
we focus on pandemic prevention, and we focus on climate.
And taking those in reverse order,
we're simply not going to meet our Paris climate Agreement
goals of keeping climate change below 1.5 degrees Celsius
by 2050, relative to pre-industrial levels.
It's literally impossible unless we address food
and agriculture.
And this is pretty much the only solution
that scales globally.
And then antibiotic resistance,
something like 70 to 80% of antibiotics produced globally
are fed to farm animals.
The UK government says, the threat from antibiotic
resistance is greater to the human race
than the threat from climate change.
It's literally the end of modern medicine
if antibiotics stop working.
So, the former head of the World Health Organization,
she said, "we are on a trajectory
that eliminates modern medicine if we stay
on our current path with regard to antibiotics."
And this is one where people will say, especially in Europe,
we're making huge progress, we're gonna ban them in Europe,
but look at China, look at developing economies,
if you ban them in Europe and you don't be on them
anywhere else, you know, it's better than not banning them
in Europe, but it's not a global solution.
And then the last one, the third one is pandemic prevention.
And the UN Environment Program last July released a report,
"Preventing the Next Pandemic" is the title of it.
They listed the seven most likely causes
of the next pandemic.
The first one is just, meat-eating period.
Because the more animals that you have,
the more likely they are to have a zoonotic disease
that transfers to human beings, boom,
we have the next COVID and it could be more transmissible
and it could be more deadly.
The second most likely cause of the next pandemic
is industrial animal agriculture,
because the more you are raising those animals intensively
that compromises their immune systems and makes, you know,
step one, even more likely.
And then the way that we are using land and encroaching
on wild animals, I think is number four,
and climate change is number number seven.
Mm-hmm, mm-hmm.
So you're literally looking at the two most likely causes,
the possibility of your food causing antibiotic resistance
or the next pandemic goes from significant to zero
if you go with plant-based and cultivated meat.
And then finally climate change.
It's a fraction of the climate change.
You eliminate nitrous oxide from maneuver decomposition,
and you eliminate methane from ruminant digestion.
And because it's fewer stages of production,
you also eliminate a lot of the CO2,
nitrous oxide is 300 times as powerful as a greenhouse gas,
methane is 20 times as powerful as carbon dioxide
as a greenhouse gas and far less land.
So, those are the three things we talk about the most.
And of course for, you know, people like you and me,
the fact that it eliminates the factory farming
as well as also, a pretty big advantage.
Sure.
I feel like the antibiotic resistance conversation
needs a publicity lift.
You know what I mean?
I don't feel like we talk about that enough.
It is such an existential threat.
So talk a little bit more about that specific issue.
I mean, what is it, 70% you said, of all antibiotics
are fed to livestock.
Why is that the case and how does that lead to,
the resistance that could, you know,
make antibiotics in human use defunct?
Yeah. So if you get an infection
and your doctor prescribes a course of antibiotics,
you'll take those four at the outside 10 days.
Farming animals are on antibiotics for their entire lives.
And that's why 70% of all antibiotics produced globally
are fed to farm animals.
Not because they're sick,
but because they would be sick given the, you know,
the intense proximity and the living conditions.
Yeah. It's a compliment.
It does cause them to grow more quickly,
so you need less feed
if you're feeding the animals antibiotics
so it has that sort of ancillary benefit to them farmer.
But yes, it also means that conditions that would otherwise
lead to massive death losses,
don't lead to massive death losses because you're using
antibiotics prophylactically.
And I mean, if people want to scare Google,
the end of working antibiotics,
if you want an even bigger scare,
add the word China to that.
There was a piece on the front page
of The New York Times Magazine, maybe 18 months ago
called Pig Zero, which you can quickly and easily
find by Googling Pig Zero.
You're literally talking about 10 million people a year
dying from antibiotic resistance on our current trajectory
by the year 2050.
And the reason for that is that, these antibiotics
are dual use, they're also used in human beings.
So we treat antibiotic prescriptions very, very seriously.
And at the same time-
When constantly consuming them.
You know, for a lot of people three times a day.
Yeah. It's less that we're consuming them,
it's less that there's antibiotic resistance in the meat
although there is, in some instances
antibiotics in the meat.
It's more that the bugs the antibiotics are designed
to kill, become super bugs when they figure out,
how to meet the antibiotics.
And then we get infected with those bugs,
and you cut your leg and they need to amputate, right?
I mean, it's antibiotics stop working
and that's really a game over for modern medicine.
Right.
And what is the current state of,
or statistical landscape with respect to the climate impact
of animal agriculture?
Yeah, I mean,
there are two ways to talk about this,
and we're working with some folks
at ClimateWorks Foundation and climate advisors
and the thing that they're really stressing on
is missed opportunity in terms of land use,
which is also a big biodiversity issue.
So the way we have generally talked about it is,
direct emissions, which is huge in itself.
The UN Food and Agriculture Organization says that 14.5%
of all direct emissions climate change is attributable
to animal agriculture.
So, that's significantly more than all forms
of transportation combined.
And the folks at Project Drawdown,
their scientists put out what are the most effective ways
that we can address climate,
and they found that moving away from farming animals
would be six times as efficient at keeping climate change
under 1.5 degrees Celsius,
six times as efficient as total electrification of transport
and eight times as efficient
if your goal is 2.0 degrees Celsius.
On a sort of per meal basis,
chicken is the least climate change inducing meat,
and it causes 40 times as much climate change per calorie
of protein relative to legumes like soy and peas.
So it's a massive direct climate impact.
It's what I said a minute ago about methane
and nitrous oxide, which are 20 and 300 times as potent
as a climate change gas.
And switching away from animal agriculture
it eliminates ruminant digestion
and it eliminates manure decomposition.
So, just those guesses are gone.
But you're also talking about massive land opportunity,
both to stop burning down the Amazon rainforest.
90% of the global soy crop is fed to farm animals,
it doesn't go into tofu or veggie burgers.
And if you don't need all of that land to grow soy
or to graze cattle, you're literally freeing up
three quarters of the land that's used for agriculture.
You go from needing 4 billion hectors of land
to needing 1 billion Hector of land.
And that freed up land, I mean, both A, you're lessening
the biodiversity loss that comes and chopping down trees,
which has massive adverse carbon impact,
but you also free up land to do other things.
So, you can free up that land for onshore wind,
you can free up that land for regenerative ranching
if that's something that you're enthusiastic about,
you can free up that land to stop monocropping
and start cover cropping.
So, there's sort of two different ways
that a shift to plant-based and cultivated meat
is a huge benefit to the climate.
So that 15% quote doesn't comprehend
the massive inefficiencies in the land being free.
Like if you were to really take a comprehensive view
of this, the impact of making the switch is much broader
and more massive than simply reducing that 15% down to 1%
or whatever.
Yeah. The opportunities for carbon sequestration
and repurposing land on behalf of climate
are absolutely colossal.
Right.
In and of themselves, even if you don't include
the direct adverse climate impact.
So, I mean, this is why GFI's organizational battle cry
is governments should be funding this transition.
Governments put money, you know,
hundreds of billions of dollars
into global health initiatives.
COVID costs the global economy, I don't know,
but it's in the trillions of dollars.
So governments should be stopping the next pandemic,
they should be keeping antibiotics working,
and as a part of their climate strategy,
they're already putting tens of billions of dollars
into renewable energy.
As a part of their climate strategy,
they should be funding open access science,
and they should be incentivizing this transition.
Right. And it's that battle cry, and that mission of GFI
that prompted as reclined to write that op-ed piece,
right?
The moonshot for meatless meat,
which caused quite a kerfuffle among certain people,
because I think it was, you know,
an accurate reflection of what you just said,
and I was so happy that he wrote that piece,
but there's another, you know,
there was a sort of misinterpretation of that,
a kind of bad faith construal of it to mean that, you know,
governments are gonna comply or they're gonna, you know,
compel people to only eat plant-based meat,
and they're gonna take away people's cheeseburgers
and it became this political talking point
that wasn't really rooted in anything real.
I mean, Ezra was a little disappointed
that the piece came out right then,
because it was actually two different things,
the Biden is going to take your burger-
Right.
Was separate from the Ezra Klein pleat piece,
which was sort of interesting.
The Biden is going to-
They seemed like they came around the same time.
They came at almost exactly the same time,
but the Biden's gonna take your burger came from,
some science into the climate impact.
I mean, it basically was based in a tabloid in the UK
called the Daily Mail,
claiming Biden was gonna take your burger
on the basis of a scientific advisor
to the Biden administration writing
for a peer review journal about the adverse impact
of meat production on climate change.
At the same time that Biden was rolling out
his infrastructure package
and it came right before the climate leaders summit
on Earth Day with John Kerry, but they were separated,
but conflated in some people's minds.
Right, right.
(Rich laughing)
It became quite an interesting thing on Twitter,
when that was exploding.
Yeah, yeah.
It was unfortunate because I mean,
one of the things that we do at GFI is stay very far away
from anybody's gonna try to take your burger.
So we see, I mean, again, analogizing to renewable energy
and electrification of transport, in both of those cases,
the idea is not to convince anybody to put solar panels yet.
The big idea is not,
I'm gonna convince you to put solar panels on your car.
Right.
And it's not, I'm gonna convince you to pay more
for an electric car, and you're gonna have to, you know,
it's gonna be inconvenient if you wanna go a long distance.
The reason solar is less than 2% of energy
and the reason electric cars are less than 1% of cars
is that there is still a green premium,
and the real trick is to make the lithium ion batteries
more effective and affordable.
And the real trick is to make the solar panels
more efficient and less expensive
in the same way GFI is focused on the supply side of this.
We want plant-based meat and cultivated meat,
as we've been talking about to simply be the way
meat is produced.
So we're not the people going door to door,
telling people to put solar panels on their houses
or to drive electric vehicles, we're the people
behind the scene, pushing to make sure that the solar panels
and the lithium ion batteries are more efficient
and less expensive.
That's what we see as our role.
So we stay out of the, trying to convince people to eat less
or no meat, because we are laser focused
on what feels like it's going to be a lot more
politically palatable, especially if we can frame it
in terms of international cooperation and innovation
and farmers and jobs,
which is a very easy framing to do,
especially the out innovate China aspect of it.
Yeah.
So if we can focus there,
we're hoping we can do something, you know,
bipartisan and focused on American ingenuity
or Chinese ingenuity for that matter as sort of the framing.
They call it attraction rather than promotion in AA.
That's a big slogan.
And that's exactly what you're talking about.
I mean, it should be a bipartisan issue,
it should be something that everybody's on board with,
and as we reckon with how to compete with China
and recognizing that China, you know,
basically has monopolized the battery market
and outpaced us in that regard, which, you know,
puts us as a nation, you know, in a deficiency.
We have an opportunity with plant-based meat and cultivated
meat to lead the charge and be, you know,
the sort of leader in this space.
And that should be something that Washington
should get behind.
And I think, you know, we'd all be well-advised
to put together some kind of Manhattan project,
moonshot type, you know, wonky brain trust in Washington,
which is part of what you're doing
to really pioneer all of this.
Yeah, no, that's exactly right.
And, I mean, we look at solar panels in the United States,
80% of them are made in China.
Or you look at lithium-ion batteries for electrification
of transport, and the Chinese have 93 gigafactories
for lithium-ion batteries.
The U.S. has four.
In 10 years China's gonna have 140, we're gonna have 10.
So, The American Jobs Plan from Joe Biden,
it has three focuses.
The first is jobs, the second is infrastructure,
and the third is out innovate China,
which seems like the sort of,
one super bipartisan aspect of it.
It's not really a trick to say, look at China,
winning on solar panels, let's make solar panels,
and look at China, winning on lithium-ion batteries,
let's make lithium-ion batteries.
Right now we are the global uncontested leader
on private sector innovation in plant-based
and cultivated meat,
but we're not very far into the race yet.
It would not take a significant investment for China
to be way ahead very, very quickly.
And our hope is that we can learn the lessons
of solar panels and lithium-ion batteries,
'cause we don't think the decision is between,
let's have conventional agriculture
and let's have plant-based and cultivated meat.
Plant-based and cultivated meat assuming it works out
and we can in fact, make these products less expensive
and indistinguishable, which we're optimistic about,
do we want that stuff made in the United States?
Or do we want to import it like we are with solar panels
and lithium-ion batteries?
And that argument is, you know, should resonate, you know,
in a bipartisan way and framing in terms of, you know,
jobs and American ingenuity.
And what we're looking for is something like
the Manhattan project focused on meat or a space race,
a global space race focused on shifting in this direction.
Right, right.
And you're contending with, you know, a regime in China
that when they set their mind to doing something,
they're able to execute on that pretty efficiently
because they...It's not a democratic society
so, we have that layered on top of this,
and then there's this campaign to win hearts and minds
because, you know, the politicization of this is that,
it could be perceived as a threat to the American way.
We're about like, you know, barbecuing in the backyards
and then, you know, the cheeseburger is what it is
to be American, right?
The T-bone steak and all of that.
And for those who's constituents are cattle ranchers,
and the like, you know,
they're gonna get up in front of Congress and, you know,
shout to the balcony about how, you know,
we can't be doing this, we need to protect, you know,
this idea that we have about what an American farmer is,
that actually is detached from the reality
of what it is to be an American farmer.
Yeah. And one of our pitches,
and I think Ezra in his piece put it really nicely.
He said something like,
"surely if we can incentivize farming practices
that are bad for the land, we can shift to incentivizing
farming practices that are good for the land."
Farmers understand what is good for the land
and what is not good for the land
and if you talk to farmers,
they're not excited about monocropping
and even cattle ranchers are not excited
about shipping their cattle to feedlots.
They're not excited about shipping those animals
to these sort of massive slaughterhouses.
I think we could in GFIs vision, move to the sort of,
less meat, better meat scenario for people
who want regeneratively farmed animals or heritage breeds.
And for cattle ranchers, what it would mean
is they could actually be incentivized
to do regenerative ranching like the folks at Carbon180,
or Advocating, or Allan Savory,
or that film, "Kiss the Ground,"
like what they are advocating,
that could be the only form of meat production
and commodity meat, which is right now, basically 100%
of pork and chicken and Turkey,
and commodity beef, which is, you know,
sort of, if the animals grazed for half of their life
and then in a feedlot for half of their life,
like how do you grapple with that exactly.
Right.
We could shift away from the feedlots,
which are so environmentally damaging.
And if regenerative ranching has promise
and I think done right it probably does have promise,
that could be the exclusive way that meat is produced.
And it ends up being really good for farmers
and not bad for farmers.
That's the vision-
And, you know, most farmers would prefer
to be able to do it that way
if they can make it economically viable.
And I think that goes to the heart of a counter-argument
to, you know, the GFI mission which is,
why do we have to do all this plant-based meat
and culture meat?
Why don't we just eat, you know,
grass fed beef from these regenerative farms?
But the truth is, there's not enough land
to feed this many people doing it that way.
And as of right now, not only is it more expensive
to purchase meat that way,
it only accounts for something like,
1/2 of 1% of the market.
So we have this romantic idea of the viability of that,
but the truth is, it's not a solution to feeding the planet.
Yeah. And I mean, this works as a pretty nice compliment
to that because it requires so much less land,
there is less land stress,
so it just, it makes regenerative ranching easier.
So, the really great thing about plant-based
and cultivated meat from a global solutions standpoint
is that it doesn't require a ton of coordination
and it doesn't require that consumers pay more.
So, regenerative ranching, assuming that it is viable
and based on people I'm talking to, I think it's viable,
but it does require oversight.
It does require a fair amount of effort
and the products are going to cost more.
Some people will pay more.
Maybe we go up from where we are now at 1/2 of 1%
to 2 or 3% or something like that.
And as we replace all of the commodity products,
all of the lowest common denominator products,
then you end up with the vast majority of meat is produced
from plants or cultivation, but there's still a market
for people who want to do regenerative ranching
and heritage breeds and consumers who want to pay more
for those sorts of systems.
Mm-hmm.
Talk a little bit about the inefficiencies
and the food waste that's caused by our current system.
I mean, you alluded to it in terms of the amount of land
required to raise animals for food, for human consumption.
But when we think about food waste, we think about the food
that we're tossing out in the garbage
or the food that goes down the garbage disposal
or into the compost,
but food waste is actually a much larger, broader issue.
Yeah, this was actually what turned me plant-based
33 years ago.
I read "Diet for a Small Planet" by Frances Moore Lappé.
And she makes an argument that just like
had not occurred to me somehow growing up in Oklahoma,
eating basically nothing but meat.
And that is that animals need to eat too.
So, according to the World Resources Institute,
the most efficient animal at turning the crops that you grow
into meat, by feeding those crops to the animal,
the most efficient animal is the chicken,
and it takes nine calories of soy or wheat or oats
or whatever you're growing.
It takes nine calories into a chicken to get one calorie
back out from the chicken.
So that means nine times as much land,
nine times as much water, nine times the pesticides
and herbicides, and then you're growing all of those crops
and you're shipping them to a feed mill,
and that is pollution, spewing and energy intensive.
And you're operating the feed mill
and you're shipping the feed to the modern industrial farm
on gas guzzling, 18 wheelers that are pollution, spewing,
and energy intensive, and you're operating the farm.
And then you're shipping the animals to the slaughterhouse
and you're operating the slaughterhouse.
So it's both the rank inefficiency of nine calories inn
to get one calorie back out,
as well as all these other stages of production.
And with cattle, it's 40 calories inn
to get one calorie back out, it's horribly inefficient.
And you have to do deal with all the refuse
that that causes as well.
Yeah. It's a massive amount of amount of water,
it's a massive amount of manure, the manure is destroying
aquatic ecosystems, it's destroying soil,
it's, you know, rendering soil barren essentially.
And yeah, I mean, it's basically cities and cities
and cities of untreated waste.
Like, you know, you're at... We're in Los Angeles,
like, the waste is treated, but there's, you know,
Harris Ranch just up the road and-
I know.
The waste is not treated.
You can't drive by that without knowing
what's going on there.
It's quite a sight and quite a smell when you pass it.
And, you know, and also as this accelerant
to climate change, I mean,
it becomes a social justice issue at the same time
because the communities that are gonna be most heavily
impacted by the seismic shifts in climate are going to be,
you know, the sort of underprivileged communities
or the sort of sea bearing, you know, cities
that are on low-lying lands that are just gonna get
devastated by this.
Yeah. I mean, COVID 19, we had 700 million people
in abject poverty globally.
Before COVID 19 we have 900 million people
in abject poverty now, after COVID-19,
it's probably even worse considering what's happening
in India and Brazil at the moment.
And we're probably, you know,
like we're sort of out of it in the United States
and not paying that close attention to what's happening
in places like India or Brazil,
but they're very much not out of it yet.
So, when you're talking about climate change
or antibiotic resistance or pandemic prevention
and pandemic adaptation, it's absolutely true that globally,
the people who can least adapt,
are the people who are going to be most adversely affected.
And they're also the folks who contributed the least
to the problems.
So, from a sort of global social justice perspective,
the planet is on fire in multiple different ways,
not just climate change, also pandemic risk,
also the end of modern medicine
through antibiotic resistance.
And it is an absolute moral imperative
that we move in this direction as quickly as possible.
And back to the idea of something like,
regenerative agriculture, or unionizing slaughterhouses,
or getting rid of agricultural subsidies,
like those are all really good things to do,
but they take a lot of work, they take a lot of coordination
and we succeed on all three of those in the United States.
And the 95% of the globe that is not the United States
has not changed at all.
So, the real sort of wonderful thing about shifting
to plant-based meat and cultivated meat,
and the reason that it analogizes to electrification
of transport and renewable energy is that,
if we can get the numbers right,
if we can make the product that people like at a lower cost,
it simply takes over and becomes how meat is made
with all of these massive benefits.
Right.
Well, speaking of products that people like,
let's talk about the current state of a plant-based meat,
like focusing on that.
At this point I would say that majority of the people
who are watching or listening to this have probably tried
a Beyond Burger, Beyond Meat, or an Impossible Burger
at this point, it's quite something,
the extent to which this has become ubiquitous
and can be found in most of the fast food chains
at this point.
And, you know, as I've started traveling again,
and, you know, there's Beyond Burger on the menu
at most restaurants that serve hamburgers now, it's crazy.
So where are we at and what's to come?
Yeah, it has been extraordinarily gratifying
to see the success of both The Beyond Burger
and The Impossible Burger,
and also the success of those companies.
So, I remember when, Beyond Garden to TGI Friday's
like three or four years ago, and everybody was so excited.
And like you said, you know, right after that White Castle
had The Impossible Burger and then,
Carl's Jr had The Beyond Burger and then Burger King
had The Impossible Burger.
And yeah, it's really, really great.
And there has been significant displacement,
even at higher price points,
but you're not gonna see massive displacement,
you're not gonna see this...
You're not gonna see the benefits that could come
until we get the price down that tastes identical or better,
and all of the products.
So, Ethan Brown at Beyond Meat in his most recent quarterly
call, because now they've IPOs,
you didn't get a lot more public information.
And he said, they expect to reach price parity
with at least one product by the end of 2024.
So, 2 1/2 years from now, right now at grocery
you're paying something like 80% more on menus,
you're paying like 20 to 30% more impossible
as a little more than twice the cost.
Yeah, it's more expensive
and people are still doing it though.
It's, yeah, no, it's... And that proves the point
I made a second ago that people right now eat meat
despite how it's produced, not because of how it's produced.
And these are very new products as well.
So, people are sort of very, very excited about them.
Their, you know, margins in terms of sales
are just skyrocketing.
We saw in 2020, 45% more plant meat consumed in 2020
as opposed to 2019, but they're starting from, you know,
a pretty low place.
So you can have that happen in 2020,
even with conventional meat consumption going up
a few percentage points,
and it's still going to be, you know, more than ever before.
And so the solution really is that, I mean,
this is one of the reasons that GFI somewhat controversially
is very excited about JBS and Tyson and Cargill
and Smithfield and BRF.
Those are the five biggest meat companies in the world,
about them going into plant-based meat,
both because if they see it as opportunity,
they can mainstream it,
and then also if they see it as threat,
they will do things to fight against it.
And we would love for them to mainstream it.
They also have massive distribution channels,
they have massive capacity to scale up,
but the reason that people like Pat Brown,
who runs Impossible and Ethan Brown, who runs Beyond,
no relation, the reason they are excited
about this sort of competition
is they are creating a market sector.
So right now, success for Beyond is success for Impossible
and vice-a-versa because it puts into people's brains
the idea that meat can come from plants.
And similarly when actual meat companies
start making meat from plants,
it really does help the general public to understand this,
and it socializes it and it moves it in the right direction.
Yeah, that's amazing.
I mean, first of all, to reach price parody,
when you're competing with, you know,
a huge amount of subsidies that are underwriting
the cattle industry, that are driving that price point down
and to be able to meet that nonetheless is an amazing thing.
Secondly, yeah, you gotta work within the system.
If you wanna create systemic change at the highest level,
it's easy and perhaps even lazy to just point your finger
at the bad guys and claim that they should go away,
but they're not going away.
So, how do you get them to change?
You go to them and you convince them
that it is in their long-term self-interest
and economic interests to make this pivot.
I've heard you say this before.
Like, they're not in the business
of necessarily slaughtering animals they are in the business
of providing protein to humans.
So if you provide them with a better way to do that,
that's cost-effective, that people like
where they can make money, they will make that shift.
Yeah, no, that is exactly right.
If they can make more money making meat from plants,
and if they can satisfy their consumer base,
cultivating meat from cells,
that is the direction that they will go in.
And it has been extremely gratifying to see all of the top-
Have you gone to these companies
and sat at their conference room tables
and talk to these guys?
Like, what is that like?
It's just like sitting and talking with anybody else.
Honestly, I mean, this is one of the things
that I just absolutely believe to be true
about human beings.
Everybody is sort of, you know, in the Dale Carnegie way,
everybody is the hero of their own story,
but folks have families and they want their families
to be proud of them.
And everybody wants their life to be meaningful.
And if your current story is,
my life is meaningful because I provide high quality protein
to lots and lots of people at reasonable prices,
that's a pretty good story.
There's a little bit of cognitive dissonance that comes
if there are all these ancillary harms
that you're partly responsible for and it's not that hard
to sort of say, yes, this is an ancillary harm,
but life is imperfect and what I'm doing
is a net really, really good.
But if you can improve on that, you know,
everybody wants their kids to be proud of them,
everybody wants their spouse to be proud of them,
everybody wants to be proud of themselves.
So, having conversations with people at these companies
and saying, look, your product is not super sustainable,
your product causes animals to suffer,
your product has these, you know, risks,
where global health is concerned and here's a solution.
And that's why all five of the biggest meat companies
in the world are investing in plant.
They all have plant-based products.
Two of them have invested
in multiple cultivated meat companies.
One of them has signed a joint venture agreement
to bring cultivated meat to Brazil.
And it makes a ton of sense, but, I mean, one thing is,
the meat companies are not, and just capitalism in general,
doesn't incentivize the sort of forward thinking
that is required for them to prioritize these products.
And the degree to which they all have,
I see as just maybe the most surprising,
and also the best thing that I've seen,
that I would not have predicted since starting GFI
five years ago.
So when you look at these various offerings
at Burger King and Carl's Jr and White Castle,
and now like Yum Foods with Taco Bell and Pizza Hut,
what is the success level like?
My sense is that these things are selling really well
and people are enjoying them.
Are there statistics on like how often people
are opting for, the plant-based burger
versus the regular burger?
I mean, it's pretty remarkable that the numbers are good,
they don't have to share the numbers.
And a lot of them they're not sharing,
but they're good enough to keep them on the menus.
I mean, the thing about fast food menus is it's no longer,
you just punch in the price.
Like you need to sell well enough
to have one of the buttons on register.
The TGI Friday Burger is still there, The Beyond Burger...
Yeah, they're all still there and they seem to be selling.
And I go in, like, I go in and purchase these things
and I will just ask the person behind the counter, you know,
how's the selling?
And inevitably they'll say, it's selling really well.
Right.
So, I mean, there were some sort of hilarious,
early false starts.
My wife is Canadian so we're in Canada and and A&W,
very, you know, sort of, to match fanfare
announced that they were gonna be launching
the Beyond Burger and Canadian A&W,
and literally all of the people had Beyond Burger aprons
and Beyond Burger hats.
And for most of the promotion, there were no Beyond Burgers
because they sold out so quickly.
But it's nice to see, you know, Beyond Us scaling up
and getting, you know, better and more secure distribution
and Possible has signed with OSI,
which is McDonald's global distributors.
So they should not have any trouble, but-
McDonald's is the final, like pin to drop here
in terms of the big players,
they have yet to really onboard this,
but they struck a deal with Beyond, right?
They did, they struck a deal with Beyond.
It's very exciting and they've tested it in a few places
and we're hearing very good things about the test marketing.
So, yeah, it's exciting.
Perhaps this is an obvious point,
but I think it's important to say that,
this product in these fast food restaurants
is not a reaction to vegan demand.
They're not offering these things because there are so many
vegans who want it, they're creating a viable alternative
to meat, and this is really a vehicle
to provide an alternative to the meat eater.
Right?
I mean, most of these burgers come with cheese on them,
they're not vegan products
and they're not trying to be vegan products.
Yeah, the default is inevitably not vegan.
And yeah, I mean, it's disheartening for somebody
who's, you know, been vegan for 33 years to-
Or cooking it on the same grill as the, as the meat,
you know, generally so-
That doesn't bother me.
So, if you're the super hardcore, you know,
this is not for you.
Like, this is not the product, this wasn't designed for you,
this is designed to play placate, not placate,
that's the wrong word, but to please the meat eater
who's just looking for a different option.
And the fact that it's not only viable,
but like working and successful,
I think bodes well for the future expansion
of these types of products.
Yeah. And the thing I was gonna say is disheartening.
It's just that the numbers of vegetarians and vegans
have not changed very much since I went vegan 33 years.
You've been doing this for a long time, Bruce.
And yeah, I mean, and what that means is exactly
what you just said.
McDonald's and Burger King and all the folks
who are looking in this direction,
they would not do this for vegetarians and vegans
because when the polls are done,
even though saying you are a vegetarian or a vegan
is a little bit more popular than it's been in past years
when they actually do the, which of these products
have you consumed in the last month.
The numbers are not higher than they were 10 or 20 years ago
and not much higher within the range
of statistical insignificance.
And then back to what I said a minute ago,
2019 was the highest per capita meat consumption
in recorded history, even in the United States.
So, the companies that are launching these products
are launching these products for meat eaters,
who are looking for something different,
which is very heartening-
Right?
Very exciting.
There's so much intense science that goes I
into the crafting of these products.
There are all these crazy engineers and people
who are expert in flavor and all of this,
it's like, it's wild to see the brain trust
that comes together to try to craft these products.
Yeah. I mean, it's pretty fascinating
to like tour beyond meat,
and they actually have all of these meat scientists
'cause they're making meat.
So, all of these people who, you know,
they went to Texas A&M or they went to Georgia Tech,
or they went wherever and they thought they were going to be
working in a Tyson lab, you know,
doing something with chicken nuggets
and now they're at Beyond Meat and doing something
with plant-based nuggets, which is pretty, pretty cool.
But that underlines the degree to which the theory
is super simple, right?
It's super simple to say, let's just grow cells
and then market the cells
and it's a better way of producing meat.
Or it's super simple to say, meat is lipids,
amino is minerals and water,
plants have all of those things,
let's just put them together and they will be a burger.
It's not that easy.
You know, we've got The Impossible Burger
and The Beyond Burger and in terms of products
that satisfy mediators so far, that's it.
And they cost a lot more.
So we do need to hire tissue engineers and meat scientists
and chemical engineers and mechanical engineers,
and we need all of the products like so far,
we've got burgers,
but we need nuggets and we need fish sticks
and those things are like super cheap.
So, we are optimistic with both plant-based
and cultivated meat that especially with economies of scale,
these practices are so much more efficient
that we should be able to get to taste the same or better
and cost the same or less all the way up to chicken breasts
and fish sticks and filet of fish and T-bone steaks.
But it is a moral imperative that we get there
for all of these products,
for the reasons that we've been talking about.
So, it really does warrant an all hands on deck mentality,
and it really does warrant governments seeing this
as an imperative within their global health
and their climate mitigation strategies.
Setting aside the moral imperative for a moment
to play a little bit of devil's advocate.
When you describe what you just described,
it's hard for me not to, you know,
conjure this notion that this is all crazy frank and food,
and it's very processed.
And what are the long-term implications on human health
by eating these foods that are made in a lab
versus, you know, grown at a farm?
I mean, on the cultivated side,
it's the exact same product,
but without any antibiotic residues,
without the equelae or Salomonae.
Right, we'll get into the cultivated meat
part of it in a minute.
But just with respect to the plant-based foods,
meat and dairy analogs.
I mean, you know, Google processing and chicken
or processing and pork or processing and beef,
there are all kinds of chemical bathers and other things
that go into meat processing now, at the end of the day,
do the macro nutrient analysis.
And you're looking at plant-based meat.
It has complex carbohydrates, it has fiber,
it has no cholesterol, it has significantly less fat,
it has the same or less saturated fat.
The macro nutrient analysis is significantly better.
We're all supposed to eat more fiber.
97% of Americans are not consuming enough enough fiber.
This helps with that.
We're all supposed to eat more complex carbohydrates,
we're supposed to eat less cholesterol,
we're supposed to eat no trans fats.
Animal meat naturally has trans fats,
plant-based meat has nutrients fats.
And this is why when the Stanford School of Medicine
did a study called Swap Meat,
and they took a variety of organic animal meats
and they compared it to Beyond Meats versions
of those organic animal meats, and in just eight weeks,
people's heart disease markers got better,
and they lost weight, which the researchers didn't expect.
And they published this in the American Journal
of Clinical Nutrition.
And it's pretty predictable
from a straight macro nutrient analysis.
And then for people that are concerned
about people in developing economies, actually, you know,
Tofu is processed and Hamas is processed,
to the processing of the plant proteins
makes them more bioavailable for athletes
and more bioavailable, much more importantly
and significantly for people in developing economies.
The protein for people who are protein deficient
is actually a higher quality protein.
You know, in the U.S. we're not protein deficient
so it probably doesn't matter that much,
but plant-based meat as a sort of solution globally,
it's a more bioavailable and consequently,
a better protein source.
Sure.
Beyond Beyond and Beyond Impossible,
like these big players that we have,
there are so many startups that are doing interesting
things, and it's been cool to kind of, you know,
pay attention to these new companies that are percolating up
and things that are happening with like fungi,
like they're making plant-based meat out of mushrooms
essentially, and they're making leather out of it.
And it's really a product of like these amazing scientists
who are figuring out how to use these things
that we've always had in our lives
and discover new purposes for them that solve these big
problems that we have.
Yeah. Well, GFI had been putting mycoprotein
and whole biomass fermentation into the plant based camp,
just because people get confused when you start talking
about fermented meat.
But yeah, I mean, Quorn has been around since 1985
doing whole biomass fermentation-
Q-U-O-R-N, right?
Q-U-O-R-N, yeah.
They're the biggest of the alternative meat companies
in the world still.
Oh, I didn't know that, I didn't know they were that big.
Largely European.
So they're omnipresent in Europe,
a little less omnipresent here, but, yeah,
they've been doing a whole biomass fermentation since 1985,
but there are a small army of whole biomass fermentations
coming along in just the last couple of years,
and it's pretty exciting.
And then there's also precision fermentation,
which is basically programming a yeast stir, a plant,
to create the actual animal proteins,
dairy proteins or egg proteins,
or in the case of impossible foods, heme proteins,
so they use precision fermentation to create the heme
that goes into their burgers.
But-
Right.
Yeah, just an overwhelming amount of exciting stuff
happening in the startup world.
Right.
What's the angle that our mutual friend, Paul Shapiro,
has taken with his Better Meat Company?
That is very exciting what Better Meat Company
and Paul are doing.
They're doing mycoprotein
so they're doing whole biomass fermentation
and they're doing it as ingredients for actual animal meat
and for plant-based meat.
So they are a business to business supplier,
and Purdue has a, I think they call it chicken plus nuggets
that are 50% Better Meat Company
and 15% Purdue actual chicken.
And they win in taste tests against the alternative.
And the thing that is most exciting to me
about Better Meat Companies production process
is it is already less expensive than conventional beef.
And especially as a blend,
it can already taste the same or better
and cost the same or less.
So this could be a really great way
for both the plant-based companies,
as well as the conventional animal based companies
to get some high quality protein and some fiber
lower the cholesterol and transfer numbers in their products
and massively increase their sustainability metrics.
Explain mycoprotein, it's M-Y-C-O,
it's not micro it's myco, right?
It's myco, it just means mushroom.
So it's a fungal-
It's a fungal fungal thing.
It's a fungal protein, just like Quorn.
It's the same basic thing they're calling their protein,
rhize, R-H-I-Z-E.
Yeah.
Is what the protein is called,
but it's a mycoprotein, that's a fungi.
And it uses whole biomass fermentation,
which is the environmental metrics are superb,
the protein digestibility is superb,
and Purdue and Johnsonville Sausage are already using it
and their customers are loving it.
And it's already less expensive than beef as it scales up.
This, I mean, this is all really fast too.
Four years ago, yeah.
Yeah.
It started at three years ago.
They just had the ribbon cutting.
Wow. Very cool.
The mayor of Sacramento was there.
(Rich laughing)
I know you were just there, right?
I was, yeah.
It's wild.
Sorry to interrupt the flow,
we'll be right back with more awesome.
But I want a snack a moment to talk to you
about the importance of nutrition.
The thing is most people I know actually already know
how to eat better and aspire to incorporate
more whole plants, more fruits, vegetables, seeds, beans,
and legumes into their daily routine.
Sadly, however, without the kitchen tools and support,
very few end up sticking with it.
So, because adopting a plant-based diet
transformed my life so profoundly,
and because I want everybody to experience some version
of what I've experienced,
we decided to tackle and solve this very common problem.
The solution we've devised, I'm proud to say is,
the plant power meal planner,
our affordable all-in-one digital platform that sets you up
for nutrition excellence by providing access to thousands
of highly customizable, super delicious and easy to prepare
plant-based recipes.
Everything integrates with automatic grocery delivery
and you get access to our amazing team of nutrition coaches,
seven days a week, and many other features.
To learn more and to sign up,
visit meals.richroll.com.
And right now, for a limited time,
we're offering $10 off an annual membership
when you use the promo code, rrhealth at checkout.
This is life-changing stuff people for just $1.70 a week,
literally the price of a cup of coffee.
Again, that's meals.richroll.com, promo code, rrhealth
for $10 off an annual membership.
All right.
Let's get back to the show.
(logo whooshing)
Well, let's talk about cultivated meat.
I mean, first of all,
this has gone through some nomenclature changes,
it's was lab grown meat and cell-based meat.
I guess we're calling it cultured meat now?
What is the appropriate vernacular?
We call it cultivated.
Cultivated meat.
You can cultivate your cultivated meat in a cultivator.
So, I think cultivated will probably become the nomenclature
of choice and some people are calling it cell based
because they did differentiation studies
and that's the thing that consumers most quickly
and easily understand is not industrial animal meat
that is produced in a different way.
Cultivated has pretty consistently been fine
for differentiation and one across the various metrics of,
would you consume it?
So, basically what they do is they show consumers
two packages and one will say cultivated
and the other will say, well, yeah, cultivated
and they've tested it against cultured and cell based,
and cell cultured, you add the word cell,
and people think science and they-
Yeah, and immediately gets weird.
And yeah, the metrics go down.
So cultivated, you know, from a nomenclature standpoint
is what we are using, more and more companies are using it,
and that's what we're hoping will become the nomenclature.
Culture does almost as well, but has some, you know,
Petri dish implications.
And also there is, you know,
cultured fish generally means aquaculture.
So, we're going with cultivated.
Sure. All right.
And explain for the people who are brand new to this idea,
what exactly this is.
Yeah. And I guess I should just tack onto the end of that,
when consumer surveys are done,
even if you call it in vitro meat,
even if you call it lab grown meat,
both of which do worse than cell-based,
something like a third of people are excited
to replace their meat with cultivated meat
once it costs less.
I'm assuming it tastes the same or better and costs less
like 1/3 are already excited about that,
2/3 are willing and excited to try it,
and then you ask people why wouldn't you replace it?
And they just deny the premise of the question.
So like, most people say,
well, I don't believe it's gonna cost less,
or I don't believe it's gonna taste better.
So, especially now, so early on when nobody
has had the capacity to even try it,
we feel like the consumer acceptance metrics
are pretty spectacular.
Even if they're like worst nomenclature issues.
Right.
Well, there's been this long ramp up
because we're all waiting for this stuff
to become available and, you know,
while we're sitting here waiting,
we're getting used to the idea.
Yeah. And I think once the two products
are on the shelves, people are like,
they're just not super excited about the external costs
of meat production.
Like people do eat meat despite its production,
not because of its production.
And when you have two products and one of them is safer
for you and your family.
And if you wanna go see what Upside Foods is doing,
you know, they'll stream it on the internet, you know,
get boring like that.
The transparency piece is huge.
Exactly, yeah.
And like you said earlier, they're like,
they're literally passing laws to make it illegal,
to find out what's happening on modern farms
and in modern slaughterhouses,
whereas the production process for plant based
and cultivated meat, they will stream live on the internet.
Live streaming every aspect of this.
Exactly.
So essentially,
the idea here is, you take a cell culture
from an animal biopsy and you grow that cell culture
or you protect it, or you create these cell banks
and use those to then create these meat products
that you essentially brew in these breweries,
and they grow on like a scaffold.
Yeah, that's exactly right.
So you take a biopsy, the size of a Sesame seed
from a live animal,
or you could do it from a slaughtered animal, either way.
You bathe the cells in nutrients,
you do that in a cultivator, which looks like a beer brewer.
You can do it on scaffolds,
or if you just need the cells for nuggets or burgers
or something, you don't have to do it on a scaffold.
Mm-hmm.
And then you harvest the meat.
It's a super simple process,
which was sort of fascinating for GFI.
When we started working on GFI five years ago,
we assumed that we know everything we need to know
about plant-based meat
'cause we've all been eating veggie burgers for decades.
And with cultivated meat, there was like all kinds of stuff
we had to figure out,
and it turned out the reverse of that was true,
because with cultivated meat,
you just take standard tissue engineering techniques
and scale it way up and use food grade ingredients.
And that's basically what you're doing.
And we know how in therapeutics in medicine,
we know how to do that at high price points.
That's why these two sort of fathers of cultivated meat
Mark Post, who grew the first cultivated meat burger
with $1 million from Sergei Brin is a medical doctor.
He was teaching medicine at both Harvard Medical School
and Dartmouth Medical School,
and then he went to teach tissue engineering and medicine
in the Netherlands, and then Uma Valeti from Upside Foods,
trained at Mayo and was a professor of-
Cardiology.
Cardiology,
at the University of Minnesota.
And he started Upside Foods, formerly Memphis Meats.
They're medical doctors-
Right.
And so they know how to do this.
And then with plant-based meat, it's kind of,
it's not exactly a different product,
but it's a whole different way
of thinking about the endeavor.
If you're sort of taking soy waste products
or wheat waste products, fashioning it into something
that looks like a burger or a nugget or whatever,
and charging higher price points for it.
So really figuring out how to take plant proteins
and create the entire meat experience
is a very different way of thinking about that endeavor.
And we've been using Twin Screw Extrusion literally
for decades, which is what's made for, you know,
pet food and snack food and that sort of thing.
It's almost certainly not the best way
to produce plant-based meat.
So, it really has been sort of an interesting shift
'cause cultivated meat, very, very simple,
plant-based meat, like a gazillion different ways
of thinking about it and a gazillion different ways
of thinking about the inputs.
Right. And there's this battle about,
which one is the more viable path to take, right?
Yeah.
Where should we be placing our bets?
I mean, GFI is placing its bets on both,
but what's your sense of how this will play out
over the next decade?
One thing that we have been surprised by is the number
of plant-based companies that are coming along,
and they're sort of thinking about the endeavor
in the older way.
So, one of the things that we challenge,
especially the plant based companies to do,
is to remember that Beyond Meat was started on the back
of university research from the University of Missouri.
They started working on it in 2012, I'm sorry, in 2009,
they didn't have a product for three years.
Impossible Foods, Pat, started working on that in 2011.
He's one of the foremost chemical engineers in the world.
Very accomplished scientist.
And it took him five years to have the first product,
The Impossible Burger.
So if you're starting a plant-based company and you say,
I'm the next Impossible Foods, or I'm the next Beyond Meat,
and you also say, for $10 million,
I can have a product on the market in 8 or 10 months.
Like those things don't compute.
For plant-based meat we really need to challenge
the plant-based meat companies to forget go
the short term competition with one another,
on behalf of the longer term competition
with the entire meat industry.
And with cultivated meat, that's in stark relief.
Like everybody knows if you are a cultivated meat company,
it is going to take you, you know, 3 to 10 years.
And when you come out of the gate,
you better have it super dialed
or you're gonna be dead in the water.
I mean, I know Ethan, didn't he pull the first iteration
of Beyond Off the Shelves?
He's like, it's not good enough.
Like, it has to be just as good or better
when we introduce it to the public or it's not gonna work.
Yeah. And the thing about plant-based meat though is that,
you can have a successful plant-based company
that just sells to flexitarians and vegetarians
and competes with the rest of the plant based companies.
And that is alluring for investors.
You can have a successful company that makes a fair amount
of money and delaying gratification to really hire
all of the scientists that are gonna be required
to have a plant based meat company
that competes with conventional animal meat
on taste and price metrics is harder.
So they're further out of the gate with Impossible
and Beyond there.
Sure.
And now, we think the conventional meat companies
are thinking in this way as well, but it's tough.
It's kind of anybody's guess.
Yeah.
And then there's also the, I mean, we are,
the more our scientists dive into this,
and we have 20 something scientists all over the world,
looking at this.
And the more they dive into it and we have networks
of scientists at all of the companies
like Benson Hill biosystems and Merch
and all of these other companies,
the more we dive into this, the more enthusiastic we get
about its prospects on both the plant-based
and the cultivated meat side, but nobody's done it yet.
Nobody has produced a plant-based
or a cultivated meat product that tastes the same or better,
and that costs the same or less.
And that's where we need to get to.
So we don't know with absolute certainty that it's possible.
We do know with plant-based and cultivated
that it's gonna take awhile,
especially for like chicken nuggets and fish sticks.
And so which one wins is probably gonna be to some degree,
a product of resources.
And then there's also the sort of a billionaire
that wants to change the world factor.
Like, if Jeff Bezos or Elon Musk said,
"okay, I've got Mars and I've got, you know, Amazon,
or I've got Mars and I've got Tesla."
Like if they were to say,
"gosh, the way that we're producing meat right now
is incredibly antiquated and I am going to relegate
this harmful way of producing meat to the dustbin of history
and put the resources that are necessary into, you know,
then they can pick plant-based or cultivated,
and suddenly that, you know, that becomes the one that wind.
That will be accelerant.
Yeah, but I feel like either way, it's an inevitability,
like we're headed in that direction, it's going to happen.
Cultivated meats gonna take longer.
It is interesting that I'm sure you know this.
Like Pat Brown is less sanguine about cultivated meat.
Like he told me like,
I mean, he's all in on plant based meat,
not so certain about where we're headed
with cultivated meat.
Yeah. I mean, I think,
I don't think pat has looked at the science in a while
on cultivated meat, which is perfectly understandable.
He's running a multi-billion dollar
plant-based meat company.
I will say, so GFI hired our first scientists
in June of 2016.
And when I first started working on it at the end of 2015,
I assumed that cultivated meat was going to be the province
of university researchers for quite awhile.
And Uma Valeti convinced me that it was ready
for commercialization, but not completely.
So the first thing I said to our scientists
when we hired them in June of 2016 was,
figure out whether cultivated meat can work
because GFI is agnostic.
We can go all inn on plant-based meat
if we don't think cultivated meat will work.
And the more we have dived inn,
the more optimistic we have become.
And we produced the first ever life cycle analysis,
and more to out point techno economic analysis
that included NDA information from companies.
We had 15 companies and to the government of Singapore,
their Agency for Science Technology and Research,
all participated with a company called CE Delft.
So we didn't get any of the proprietary information.
CE Delft got proprietary information from 15 companies
and worked with,
A*STAR, the government science agency of Singapore
to map the path forward.
And the more people dive in, the more enthusiastic they get
about the possibility of cultivated meat.
And it's gonna require some government support,
just like electrification of transport and solar
have required government support.
I mean, it might be inevitable
over sort of the longest timeframe if we, you know,
relegated exclusively to startup companies.
But with government support,
our scientists become more and more convinced
that it's doable.
And if that changed, you know, we stopped doing it.
Right.
So right now, Josh Tetrick's company, Just,
is serving cultivated meat in this fancy restaurant
in Singapore.
Interestingly, Just which was Hampton Creek
began as a plant-based at company-
Company.
Yeah.
And then pivoted to the cultured meat
like that came-
They do both now.
They both, right?
They just raised $200 million each-
They didn't start in the cultivated space though.
Right. They started as a plant-based aid company.
Right?
Yeah, yeah.
And that's kind of, proof of concept, you know,
slowly these things are gonna get onboarded
and we'll reach up, you know, a pivot moment
in terms of scale.
Well, when it will all become affordable.
Yeah. I think that's right.
I mean, our techno economic analysis
named sort of three areas of significant
requisite scientific inquiry on the cultivated side,
as well as some areas where governments need
to provide support similar to what they did
with Tesla in 2009, in terms of super low interest loans
for factories, that's one example, some of the ingredients,
especially albumin in the media,
either getting a synthetic version or a much lower cost
version, those sorts of things.
But, yeah, I think it is eminently, eminently doable.
I also think there's an absolute moral imperative to do it.
So this is why at GFI,
our global battle cry is convincing all of the governments
where we operate, that this needs to be a part
of their theory of change and programs
around both global health and climate change,
meeting their obligations under the Paris Agreement.
And then also just getting the global NGO community.
So, Breakthrough Energy, Bill Gates,
he launched his NGO in February.
It was a spinoff of Breakthrough Energy Ventures.
We worked with them on their policy plan around this issue,
and they are saying, and more and more environmental groups,
but we need all of them.
I mean, most environmental groups have been somewhat AWAL
on Ag and Land Solutions because they couldn't come up
with something that analogized to renewable energy
and electrification of transport.
All of the solutions either required individuals to change,
which just hasn't been working for 50 years
as like a grand plan, or it required massive amounts
of collaboration and cooperation across governments,
which is also super hard.
Renewable energy, electrification of transport,
you use markets, you use technology, that is clear.
So now the organizations that see those as a solution
to fossil fuels and yeah, to fossil fuels,
need to see this as the Ag and Land Solutions.
So that's really what we're focused on.
Yeah, that's interesting.
I hadn't really thought about that.
You can't just say stop doing that,
you have to provide an alternative
where you can direct funding and interest.
Yeah.
And now this is that thing.
Yeah. And I do just want to underline, like, you know,
Pat Brown, and Ethan Brown, and Uma Valeti, and you and me,
and lots and lots of people like, we are here
dedicating our lives to this on the basis of education.
And GFI doesn't do direct to consumer.
We do outreach to governments and outreach to NGOs
and other policy makers and corporate executives
and entrepreneurs and scientists,
and we are focused on educating people,
the people to change their lives in this direction.
But education has a way to get lots and lots of people
to change their diets, just, it hasn't worked yet,
even in the United States where we're sort of most advanced
in education, the idea that it will work in rural China
just seems not likely.
So this is the solution from a sort of grand vision way
of thinking about the problems.
Yeah. Both Brown's, Pat and Ethan, and you know,
they come into this, not as entrepreneurs
or I have this great idea and I'm gonna make a bunch
of money or I'm in the world of food,
they were looking at it from a perspective of,
this is a big problem
and I perhaps might have a solution to this.
Yeah.
It's solution oriented.
Yeah, no, that's absolutely right.
I will take this opportunity to say like the foundation
of GFI was looking at people like Pat and Ethan and Uma
and Josh Tetrick and saying, all of these guys
have the solution and then they have a company
and all of their science is protected by IP law,
which is great for them and is-
You have to do that.
But you wanna open source this stuff.
Yeah. So our first of our first six hires,
two of them were scientists and nobody before GFI had said,
what is the technological readiness of these technologies?
What are the critical technology elements?
What do we know?
What do we not know?
Where the areas of exploration?
Where were...We don't even know what we don't know.
And let's start filling those gaps.
So, the first thing we did in science and technology was,
produced the technological readiness assessments.
And we are methodically publishing peer review research,
as well as partnering with food technology,
which is the Institute of Food Technologists
member organization.
We've published three papers about plant-based
cultivated meat and fermentation and their journal,
which is the largest journal
for food technologists in the world.
We have 16 university programs.
We call it the Alt Protein Project.
So anybody who has their relevant experience
to transform the world, using food science,
across the full scope, and pretty much everything in stem
is applicable here.
We wanna make sure all of these people,
everyone knows that they can save antibiotics,
that they can lessen pandemic risk,
that they can address climate,
that they can help animals with their expertise
by going into this space.
And we are open accessing everything and we are inviting
everybody to the table.
So, we have monthly, the science of all protein seminars,
we have monthly the business of all protein seminars
and somebody the other day said,
gfi.org is the Wikipedia of all proteins.
And it absolutely is.
It's hard to imagine any question anybody could ask,
that's not answered on our website.
You recently revamped the website,
which looks great by the way,
but it's an incredibly robust resource
for everything you wanna know about this world.
Yeah, that's exactly right.
And then we have massive amounts of webinars.
So yeah, we have-
Are you're getting the conference back up on its feet?
We're not doing it in-person this year.
So the Good Food Conference, we're doing a virtual version.
I can't remember what the slogan is,
but the slogan that we scrapped was,
Not Your Grandmother's Alt Protein Conference
and a whole bunch of people didn't like that.
But it's basically.
I think my grandmother...
I don't think there was an Alt Protein Conference
at my grandmother's era.
So that may have been the fatal flaw.
But now that the idea of the conference,
we did a full day on fermentation
and it was super science-y.
Well, it was sort of fermentation 301.
So the science and the entrepreneurship and the policy
panels and presentations were all like for people
who are in fermentation and want to take it
to the next level across whole biomass fermentation
and precision fermentation.
This conference, I was looking at the schedule
that folks have put together.
And it's all like sort of policy, corporate engagement,
innovation and science 301.
So, it's sort of next level and for people
who really want to dive in,
and then we go out and we, you know, go to Cargill
and ADM and Nestle, and all of the sort of people
who are working in fields where their expertise
would be applicable here,
but aren't here yet, and say,
Hey, come learn about what it means
that you're a fermentation scientist or a meat scientist
or whatever else, and how you can apply those skills here
and all of the opportunities that exist here.
So, our 2018 and 2019 conferences were phenomenal
for getting people involved and interested and excited.
This is sort of a step up in terms of the intricacy
of the-
Wow, that's cool,
that's cool.
One of the other things that I didn't realize
and never had thought about until I heard you
talking about it with Simon Hill on his Plant Proof podcast
is the fact that, once you perfect this or not even perfect,
but once you get cultured meat up on its feet,
it's not just about steaks and chicken breasts.
Like you can literally do all these crazy delicacies,
like Foie gras, or like, you know,
just imagine the aperture opening up to,
I mean, our choice of animals that we eat
is driven by the history of domestication, right?
But then suddenly, you could culture any type of meat,
which is freaky and weird.
Or incredibly exciting and awesome.
I guess, I mean, it's like, you know,
look, you've been vegan forever and I have for a long time.
So it's not something that like
I find myself looking forward to.
But just thinking about that is super interesting.
Yeah, no, it's insanely interesting.
And I mean, this is one where Pat Brown talks about how,
if you're making beef, I mean, all the climate numbers also,
like this goes back to like, these are the climate numbers
now, when the industry is like teeny tiny,
as it scales up, the climate numbers get better,
the efficiency numbers get better,
like everything gets better.
In the same vein, if you're like, producing beef,
you're pretty limited.
Like you can feed the cows, you know,
slightly different things and sort of tweak it a little bit,
but you're pretty limited to beef and chicken
and pork and lamb.
And like, as you said, the limited number of species
who we have successfully domesticated with cultivated meat.
Yeah, you're not limited by, you know, who is domesticated.
Right. So it's gonna get weird.
It'll get nutty, right?
I don't know if weird and nutty or exactly,
I guess it depends on-
Well, it could be like, imagine any animal,
like who knows there's some animal that has a certain taste
to it that consumers might caught onto.
It's gonna get significant-
That we never thought of eating before.
Yeah, significantly different from what's happening now.
George Church, the famed tissue engineer
from Harvard Medical School has talked about,
ancient and extinct species who if we have there, you know-
Oh, he is a Mastodon guy, right?
Exactly. So we could be-
It's Jurassic Park like getting cells out of the Amber
and then cultivating them and creating meat out of them
for us to eat.
Yeah. One of my scientists is gonna email me
after this podcast drops and say, these are the nine things
that you got just absolutely wrong, but-
I don't know what I'm talking about. So, I'm okay.
Yeah. Well-
I can give that disclaimer.
I'm a bit, yeah, I'll make the disclaimer too.
Now, I'm pretty sure I haven't said anything wrong,
but on this one, I'm feeling a little out of my depths,
but I think so, yeah.
I mean, if you can find the requisite DNA
to bring those species back, I assume you can also find,
whatever you need as a starter to cultivate, you know,
cells from trends trying to source Rex or whatever.
That is wild.
I'm it is wild, I mean, you know,
it's also like exciting and awesome and interesting
and fun and cool.
(Rich laughing)
A close cousin being the 3D printing
that's going on right now with this company in Israel,
right?
Yeah. Israel, a redefined mate is one of them, but yeah,
there're a bunch of companies looking at 3D printing,
which is a nice compliment to the idea
with both plant-based and cultivated meat.
I mean, that's probably how we get T-bone steaks
and pork chops is 3D printing, so.
But if perfect, that, and you create a situation
where that's expedient and cost-effective,
that also eliminates a lot of distribution issues
and transportation issues that are contributing
to climate change, because all you would need
are the ingredients and the computer, and the printer.
Yeah, I mean, one of the climate battle cries
is electrify everything.
So that's across climate activists, electrify everything.
That's why electrify transport,
even in countries where they're relying on fossil fuels,
because you will get to renewable energy
and then you electrify transport.
Similarly, if you concentrate production,
even if it's not, you know,
the localized that you're talking about,
but if you eliminate multiple stages of production,
and you concentrate production in a factory,
and then you use renewable energy to power that factory,
this is how we make agriculture net zero emissions.
You start, you know, taking advantage
of all the freed up land and using that for cover cropping
and all of the other things that you can repurpose
that land for, or even just stop chopping down
the rainforest because the land is less in demand,
and even more positive climate benefits for sure.
Mm-hmm, mm-hmm.
It is a very energy intensive thing right now, right?
It is but, it is energy intensive,
but if you're using renewable energy, then it's like,
it's not a problem that it's energy intensive.
So that's where you go back to electrify everything.
It requires a fraction of the land
and a fraction of the water,
and doesn't contribute to air pollution
and sort of all of these benefits.
It is electricity intensive, but nevertheless,
you're still talking about huge gains even there
because of all of the extra stages of production
that are involved in conventional agriculture.
But to realize the big gains,
you do need to be using renewable energy
in the factories.
Another criticism that gets hurled in the direction
of this field is the monocropping thing, right?
'Cause we're talking about basically pea and soy.
What else are the core ingredients in these products
for the plant-based?
See, but that a pretty fundamental misunderstanding
of plant-based meat.
So it's pea and soy now, because pea and soy
is what's available and we're at very small scale,
but there are people who would like to be burrowing oats
in North Dakota and Wisconsin and other places.
And oats can help to revitalize the soil.
They can help to decrease runoff.
There are all kinds of crops and it's kind of protein,
as protein, as protein, which is what we saw
with impossible version 1.0,
moving to impossible version 2.0,
when they just changed their protein because they needed,
they're using soy because that's what they could get
in big supply.
But one of the great things about this transition is,
it requires so much less land,
which means you don't have to mono crop.
Again, 90% of soy is fed to chickens and other farm animals
right now.
You can stop monocropping, you can produce crops
that do a better job of sequestering carbon,
you can rotate your crops,
you can produce different proteins,
it will need to scale up so that the supply chain is there.
And we're not in that place yet-
Yeah, we're not out there yet.
Except with peas and soy.
But this is a solution to that problem in a really big way,
'cause the vast monocropping happens right now
because corn and soy and wheat
are the primary crops in animal feed.
You remove the animal and you make a much more efficient
process, which decreases stress on the land,
and allows for a much greater diversity.
Yeah. And as we continue to iterate
and find more diverse plant products
to use for these alternatives,
you create a more bio-diverse situation
where you can rotate those crops.
Yeah, no, that's exactly right,
that is exactly right.
And I mean, you know, speaking again,
I mean, thinking again on a global scale,
going from needing 4 billion hectors of land
to 1 billion hectares of land,
that's good for the issue of monocropping
in the United States, which is where most food activists
are thinking about it, but it's really good for people,
for subsistence farmers in rainforests
that are no longer gonna be burned down,
to grow soy for farm animals.
It's really good in the entire developing world
where land is being taken over in order to grow crops,
to feed the animals or to graze animals
because more and more people are eating meat
from a biodiversity standpoint,
both ocean biodiversity and land biodiversity,
and decreasing the inefficiency of production
is just such a boon to the natural world.
I'd like to see this move towards,
organic production as well.
I mean, I talked to Pat about this and he was like,
"look, I'd love to have organic soy
for the Impossible Burger."
There isn't enough.
It's not being produced at the scale that he required.
But if we could create that incentivization
or as new companies come online
who wanna have a premium product
and are sourcing their ingredients from organic farms,
I think we're gonna see that.
I think we will absolutely see that.
I think if you go back to anything that increases the price,
decreases the penetration.
So at least from GFIs standpoint, like people will say,
well, you should be encouraging these companies
to do organic, or you should be encouraging these companies
to do a wide range of things that would be good
for these companies to do.
Or you should, when you're meeting with JBS or Tyson
or Cargill, you should talk with them about,
treatment of slaughterhouse workers or whatever.
The analogy that our general counsel used
in a slightly different context
is the five-year-olds playing soccer
and the professional soccer team.
And one of the things that I thinks holds back Progressive's
sometimes is everybody feels like they have to do everything
and everything has to be thoroughly integrated.
And it's like, we're all charging the soccer ball
and we don't move the soccer ball forward.
(Rich laughing)
So, for GFI-
That's very funny.
We're playing professional soccer and our focus is,
let's make sure these products taste the same or better
and cost the same or less.
And if you are somebody who is in a community
that is gonna be hyper screwed by climate change,
you want plant-based meat and cultivated meat
to taste the same or better and costs the same or less
as soon as possible,
so that it can reap its maximum advantage.
And one of the things, like one of our team members said,
you know, when you're talking with JBS,
can we also talk about slaughterhouse workers?
And the question is,
do you think that we'll actually do some good?
Yeah.
No, there are lots of people talking to them
about slaughterhouse workers.
Do you think that will sever our relationship with them
and make it really hard for our scientists to meet
with their scientists?
Well, yeah, it will sever our relationship with them.
So, there are lots of organizations working on a full range
of super worthy, awesome work across the full spectrum
of food justice, but in the same way that we're not gonna go
to people who are working on slaughter house minimum wage,
or worker justice, or whatever, and say,
Hey, can you integrate plant-based and cultivated meat
into your thinking about this issue?
Because look at all the great things it does for climate
and antibiotic resistance and pandemic risk,
and you should be thinking more about that.
We don't want them to do that.
They've got their lane and they're focused on something
super worthy and important.
And then we've got our lane and we're focused on something
On the policy front, where are the, you know,
battlegrounds being drawn right now?
Like, what are the wars that you're fighting?
I mean, we're kind of aware of the labeling laws
and all the kind of shenanigans that's going on around
what you can and can't call products,
but, you know, from your perspective, you know,
being immersed in this and being in Washington, you know,
what's the biggest fight that we're facing right now,
or that you're trying to win?
We haven't hit Newton's third law in a really big way yet,
so there hasn't been much in the way of equal
and opposite reaction.
So when we're talking about like, what are the obstacles?
It's mostly inertia.
It's mostly that people are doing a gazillion things
and nobody is looking for one more thing to be put
on their plates.
So, the stuff I am most excited about all has to do with,
convincing the Global Climate Community to take food
and agriculture seriously, and to put alternative proteins
into how they think about that.
So working with the World Economic Forum on the UN Food
Systems Summit with a view of getting alternative proteins
into how the Global Community on Climate is thinking about,
solving climate problems, using Ag,
using alternative proteins,
and then moving from the UN Food System Summit
to COP26 and really making sure folks are talking about Ag
and are talking about solutions that scale globally.
And then, hey, this is the one solution
that scales globally, but it's really it's inertia.
Like you go to environmental groups,
they've set their strategic plans.
They know what they're doing for the next five years.
They don't have all of this side budget
waiting for some new initiative.
Similarly, on Capitol Hill, we have been super gratified
by how many members of Congress,
like once you go and you meet with them and you say,
Hey, nobody's talking with you about a solution
that scales in agriculture.
Here's a solution that scales in agriculture,
we organized 61, including GFI.
We organize 61 organizations to write to the relevant house
and Senate committees for the National Science Foundation
and USDA asking for $50 million each
for open access plant-based and cultivated meat research.
And we got the Mushroom Institute
and the Pea and Lentil Council.
We got Unilever, we got Merck, we got Greenpeace,
we got Consumers Union and a bunch of different groups.
And they all signed on, which is a great sign,
but none of them were like,
oh, I really need one new, you know, project
to spend a bunch of time on.
So it's really that nobody was looking for something else
to do, and we need partners.
So, so excited to be working with the world economic forum,
I'm so excited to be meeting
with so many members of Congress
who are enthusiastic about this.
Rosa DeLauro was probably the most important person
in the House of Representatives for what we're trying to do.
And she has been talking about incentivizing plant-based
and cultivated meat, R&D.
So making significant inroads in Congress is very exciting,
beginning to make inroads
with environmental non-profits is exciting,
the University Program with 16 campuses around the world,
top universities for agriculture
and food service is exciting,
the work with the big corporations,
as well as startups and investors is exciting,
and really there isn't a lot of difficult pushback,
but there is everybody is insanely busy all the time
with really good stuff and adding one more thing
to agendas is just hard.
I love the idea of creating university curriculums
in these agricultural schools specifically.
Are there some great professors who are teaching this stuff?
I mean, it seems like,
look, this is gonna be a trillion dollar business, right?
Like this is the future.
How are we training or getting young people
thinking about this and up to speed
for this emerging market.
Yeah. It's very exciting.
And we've got an entire program at Berkeley,
We've got an entire program at UC Davis,
which is the number two Ag university in the world,
we've been working with Wageningen University
in the Netherlands, which is the number one Ag university
in the world, working with them on proposals
to the government to fund even more of it.
Worked with Davis and got them applying to,
National Science Foundation.
And they got $3.5 million to do cultivated meat research.
And now they have a cultivated meat modeling consortium.
Our alternative protein project,
the 16 university chapters is just on fire.
These students, it is students who like,
they wanna save the world, they're excited about stem,
and for example, they got two Stanford professors to apply.
GFI has a Grant Program.
So we have three funders that give us a total of $5 million
every year to basically do a call for proposals
and fund White Space Research.
And that is a great opportunity
for our affiliate organizations to go to scientists
like Embrapa, which is basically the Ag Research Service
of Brazil is coming to seminars with GFI scientists.
The National Institute of Food and Agriculture at USDA
is coming to seminars with GFI scientists to like learn
about these issues, and then pairing scientists with money,
and also having a pool of money ourselves,
really sort of shifts the way that people look at GFI
and shifts the way that people think
about science in this space,
and it gives our out protein projects
on these 16 university campuses,
something to go speak with the relevant professors about.
There's this money,
and you're doing this tissue engineering work,
or you're doing this plant biology work,
what do you think about putting a proposal together
for this pool of money?
Is pretty exciting at awesome.
Wow.
What efforts are underway to facilitate the transition
of these ranchers and other farmers into, you know,
new way of doing things?
'Cause that's a big part of this, right?
People can create that opportunity.
There are a bunch of organizations
focused on that specifically.
We have, co-sponsored some legislation in California
that incentivizes transition to plant-based production.
GFI's main focus honestly, is funding the research,
and the transition on that side of things.
But we are certainly, and we expect just transition
at the policy level to come alongside this,
but right now we are early enough and there is little enough
government money that then figuring out what you do
in terms of just transition on the other side
is probably a step or two beyond,
but it's certainly something
that we're super enthusiastic about.
And we've got the Pilot Legislation in California
that we're enthusiastic about.
I look at GFI and I see it as sort of this organization
that is helping all of these budding entrepreneurs
and scientists and people who are interested in this field
turn red lights into green lights.
Like how can we be over here,
making sure that your path can unfold more smoothly
than it would otherwise?
Is that fair?
Yeah, we see ourselves, we call it, field cattle
and we call ourselves a field catalyst.
Field catalyst?
Which is sort of a think tank.
So, you know, back to gfi.org as the Wikipedia
of alternative proteins,
like we have a startup guide that won an award
from Fast Company, and we have investor resources,
and we have an overwhelming amount of open access to science
and lots of stuff for corporations to get up to speed
and investors to get up to speed.
So yeah, it's about, you know, massive facilitation
for anybody who could be a key part of this transition.
And what are the other white spaces
that you're seeing right now where you think,
here's where this is going,
or here's something that we're not paying attention to,
that we should be paying more attention to?
So we have something called advancing solutions
and alternative proteins, which is @gfi.org/asap,
which is focused on specifically answering that question.
The two big ones are scale up.
So what does it look like to even have the infrastructure
if plant-based meat continues to grow at 45%,
every single year?
And then government funding to basically,
if you take out a loan to buy a $450 million factory
on conventional terms, the CapEx costs
are sort of through the roof.
Elon Musk credits Tesla not going bankrupt in 2009
with a government incentive program
that allowed him to take out at really low cost loan.
So, incentivizing that sort of thing at the government level
is a pretty big one on cultivated meat.
Our techno-economic analysis identified albumin
and figuring out how to markedly decrease
the cost of albumin as being something that would be,
pretty critically important.
And back to working with universities.
So, Wageningen University Research,
which is the top Ag university in the world,
they looked at our ASAP,
Advancing Solutions and Alternative Proteins,
which is exactly the question you just asked,
and there's pages and pages of white space opportunities
on the website.
They looked at that and in a funding proposal
to the Dutch government, picked four of the white spaces
that we have identified as white spaces that they would like
to fill, which at GFI just elates us beyond, beyond.
'Cause our goal is to get as much activity happening
in this space as possible.
And as a field catalyst, we think in terms of 100X,
you know, not just 10X, but 100X.
So if the Dutch government can solve for these people,
these problems through Wageningen University Research
on the basis of the work that we did on ASAP,
which was about a year's worth of work
for a small team of people at GFI,
like that is just a massive, massive benefit.
And similarly, if we can incentivize governments
to put billions of dollars into open access R & D
or to incentivize private sector activity in this space,
it's, you know, way beyond just GFS resources
that opens up a massive and entire field.
And that's how we think about our corporate work,
our innovation, investor work,
our science work and our policy work.
So casting your gaze forward, I don't know, 20 years,
50 years, what is the world look like
if you are able to accomplish all of these goals
that you've set for yourself and for GFI?
What does the world look like?
Yeah.
I'm-
Imagine all the lights are green all the way,
and all these things that you're working on
and all these companies that you're babysitting
and helping facilitate and all,
and the next generation of scientists that you're, you know,
trying to birth into the world are able to go off
and do the thing.
Yeah. I mean, not even just on the plant-based
and cultivated meat side, when somebody says,
how quickly could we replace commodity meat,
so lowest common denominator meat?
How quickly could we replace that with plant-based
and cultivated meat?
Further to what you said a little bit ago,
if like somebody in China gets the fire lit under them
and they say, you know, we are as a country,
going to have bragging rights until the end of time
for being the country that made meat from plants
and cultivated meat from cells
and eliminated the pandemic risk and antibiotic use
and various other global health and environmental scorches,
slashed the climate impact of meat,
like China could make all of this happen pretty quickly.
They have world-class universities.
I mean, if you read about why solar panels
are the costs that they are now,
or why lithium-ion batteries are the costs
and are as efficient as they are now, like that's China.
And we shouldn't let that happen with meat,
so we should be able to incentivize something similar
in the United States.
And right now the U.S. is the uncontested global leader
in alternative proteins, but Israel and Singapore, you know,
coming along and their governments
are the uncontested governments
that are taking it most seriously,
but we've got Beyond and Impossible and Just
and Memphis and Bluenet low.
On that aspect of what we're talking about,
replacing lowest common denominator meat,
with meat made from plants and meat cultivated from cells
is really a question of will incentivization and funding.
And could happen pretty quickly.
And then our hope is that alongside that, you know,
back further to the professional soccer team,
our hope is that you would see,
I mean, right by definition, the jobs are better,
by definition there is less stress on land,
by definition most of the things
that would make for a truly just food system.
And, you know, we could replace commodity meat
with plant-based and cultivated meat
and change kind of none of the structures
that exist right now and that would still be-
Still treat the workers terribly,
still do all these other things that we need to change.
And that's still,
I mean, that's still, if you're, you know, somebody,
if you're one of the 700 million people
who are living in abject poverty globally,
or one of the 200 million that are, you know,
just sent there by COVID-19, like that's better,
that's a lot better than the current system.
But my ideal is that we, you know,
the professional soccer team,
we make progress across all of these issues.
And as there is less stress on the land,
we do move toward organic.
We do completely abandon monocropping and other things
that destroy the soil.
We do take what we learned in "Kiss the Earth" seriously
about soil regeneration and beating back the toxins
and everything else.
And we take worker concerns seriously,
and we incorporate environmental justice
into our thinking across all of these issues,
both factories and where the factories are placed
and how farmland is distributed and who gets incentivized.
And I think all of that gets easier if we're, you know,
if we're not incentivized to monocrop
and if we're making meat from plants and cultivating meat
from cells, I also think that we can completely rethink
our relationship with animals.
If the vast majority of people
are not in a relationship that are, you know,
supporting industrial animal agriculture,
I think we can think, in whole new and more open ways
about who animals are and how they are et cetera.
So I think this can be a part of creating
just a much better world across the full range of issues
where the world is broken right now.
Beautifully put.
I think that's a good place to wrap it up.
Can I say one last thing?
Of course.
GFI is hiring.
Yeah-
And the last-
I wasn't gonna end this, I was gonna-
Oh, okay.
I was gonna culminate it with a big monologue about GFI.
Oh, that's very nice.
(Rich laughing)
I know that you're, I mean, you've been hiring like crazy
since I met you and this has gone on unabated.
So, if people wanna get involved
in addition to just go into gfi.org and spending time
on the website and reading all of the literature
that you have available there,
there are also multiple opportunities and avenues
to get involved, but perhaps you could even get hired
by Bruce to work there.
That's exactly right.
We have a whole bunch of openings and people can find them
at gfi.org/careers.
And like you said,
we are often and somewhat constantly hiring.
So we keep growing and we do have openings,
not just in the United States, but also India, Israel,
Brazil, Asia Pacific, out of Singapore and all over Europe,
but our policy office is in Brussels.
Yeah.
And anything else that I didn't address or left out?
I mean, my hiring pitch is that,
GFI takes mindfulness very, very seriously.
We have incorporated Daniel Pink's theory
of vocational self-actualization
and how we think about working at GFI.
So, everybody gets a Headspace account.
If you work at GFI, we start our leadership team meetings,
as well as our staff meetings,
with two minutes of breathing in all things good
and breathing out all things bad.
And we really take seriously the idea that what people want
from their vocations is a high degree of figuring out
how to do your work, not being told how to do it.
So, we were calling it autonomy,
and we had some sort of misperceptions
of what autonomy means.
You're still hired to do your specific job.
To get to do whatever I want.
Yes, that was the pitfall a little bit.
But, I don't think there is a better place
to vocationally self-actualize than GFI.
And especially for people who are scientists
or policy advocates, and if you're at an environmental
organization, don't come to GFI,
get your environmental organization to go all in on this.
But this is how we stop the next pandemic,
it's how we keep antibiotics working,
it's how we address climate change.
And we really do need all hands on deck on this.
So, check out our website, get involved,
come to our webinars, come to our conferences.
And yeah, I think that's basically it.
Yeah, and be a meaningful participant in change,
positive change.
Amen do that.
It's a beautiful thing man.
Thank you my friend, I love you.
If there's anything I can do to support your work,
we live in crazy, amazing fantastical times.
It's gonna be very interesting to observe
how all of this plays out over the next couple of years.
And you're certainly welcome back here anytime
to share what you find out in the world.
Thank you so much, Rich, I love you too.
And just absolutely who you are in the world
and how you exist in the world and how you use your podcast
to raise consciousness about everything good
is just truly inspiring.
So, it's an honor to be on the podcast
and an honor to be friends and compatriots
in making the world better and more just.
So thank you.
And now, I'm gonna have to start our day here
with two minutes of breathing in good and breathing out bad.
It is so good, it is so good.
Breathing in, we are breathing in peace,
equanimity and all things good.
Breathing out we are breathing out strife,
consternation and all things bad starting now.
Amen brother.
Amen.
Peace, plants.
(upbeat music)